we need two Undercovers at the DeKalb
Street warehouse party uh Boyle you're
already in costume as Joy Behar I'm
Mario Batali okay and Santiago you go
with them yes sir damn it
Santiago I know that you hate Halloween
but stick with me and I promise you you
will love it
can you magically make everyone kind
sober and fully dressed kind sober and
fully dressed good news everyone we
found the name of Santiago's sex tape
what is all this
no I think Halloween is for jerks well
this Halloween I was the jerk I'm sorry
about tonight
I'm sorry about tonight we found the
title for Santiago's follow-up sex tape
I'm sorry I couldn't convince you to
love Halloween it's not your fault I was
terrible it's not your fault I was
terrible is also one of your sex tapes
Halloween is unbearable but it was
slightly less unbearable with you don't
dig oh this is so cool shoot around
corners I love guns I'm gonna make such
a good dad I'm not even gonna touch that
be Amy Santiago story the linoleum
awaits my dear
I know undercover but I'm starting to
get real nervous about this contest you
need to see a therapist it's dance this
way oh how did you manage to step on
both of my feet at the same time I'm
horrible at this one can we stop I'm
horrible at this right no I know title
of my sex tape yeah well done title of
my sex tape
oh my god captain could really win this
thing
how did you get so amazing at dancing
take focus I found a back stairway over
here and spin got you drink champagne
mixed with 30 year old scotch and
top-shelf tequila captain said a
two-drink maximum smart hmm oh god it's
horrible
yeah shouldn't have added the olive
juice ooh hey so listen the thing I said
to you before I went undercover about
how I wish something had happened
between us romantically that wasn't
nothing that was real what are you
saying
I know that you're with teddy I'm not
trying to change that and I get their
stuff I can't control but this morning I
told you that I didn't mean any of it
and that was a lie I just don't want to
hold anything back well thank you for
saying that just as long as we're clear
that I'm with someone and nothing is
gonna happen I'm with someone nothing's
gonna happen Amy your sex tape he's back
fine I'll get my stuff but this better
not bite me in the ass better have I
been ass named your sex tape but
seriously thank you so much for your
help
Santiago yes
before you go both of you requested to
have this Saturday off but I need one of
you to work I could take that shift our
last time you worked at Saturday you
watch the cartoons the entire time well
that's when they're on work this out and
get back to me sorry I can't reschedule
I have tickets to a TED talk on power
poses and getting what you want by using
your body
Oh Oh hope it doesn't get too sexual oh
I hope it doesn't get too sexual title
your sex tape but seriously what is
taking so long
also the title your sex tape
Yeek blast a cold air coming out of that
box name of Amy's sex tape hey man come
on not cool
I'm going through something just let me
have this one look like it I'm gonna go
grab some coffee
great hey yeah I know that it's just us
there's a thing I wanted to say yeah
does that you why doesn't your mouth
work why doesn't your mouth work title
of our sex tape your sex tape what no ah
sorry I think I'm feeling a little
awkward
yeah me too how do we make it not weird
I know let's just get super drunk yes
great idea pardon me ma'am could you
please bring us four kamikaze shots and
four for me as well ah I like your style
see we can do this we're back on track
we're keeping it light and breezy so we
broke a rule yeah I hope it wasn't a
mistake
oh it wasn't a mistake title your sex
tape title of our sex tape how do you
explain this I have no idea I put the
black in my office Jetta come here come
here come here baby
hell yeah thank you return to my office
please what's up you little turds wait
what is going on we have the plaque yeah
I just got out of the vent to rub it in
your faces I just got it out of the
bench rub it in your faces name of your
sex tape what we don't have anymore pros
we're promised oh and one more thing
they're guilty no we are not please do
not address the jury mr. Peralta but but
one more but and you will be in contempt
one more on your contempt name your sex
tapes there has to be some way to
exonerate you know I've been looking but
I can't find anything and I don't know
what to do I can't find anything and I
don't know what to do title of your sex
tape what is happening right now
they caught Hawkins trying to flee the
country she confessed to everything and
they left me yeah oh my god Jake is it
really you are you really here you know
it baby but first I got a hug my bed
bread what I saw refused I don't know
what's happening right now I'm so
confused I don't know what's happening
right now title your sex tape oh my god
I'm shaking I'm definitely gonna cry
title of your sex tape
brought the what do you have to say for
yourself
the whole NYPD knows where you are and
they're coming for you right now
okay thanks for the tip let's kill them
both get out of here before the cops
come
wait no no no I was lying about the
backup I came alone title by sex tape
okay look I hate to ask this but have
you considered shutting the truck down
you're always bragging about how much
Boyles love to give up I can't I'm in so
much debt I took out a loan for the
truck I got Amy to invest you know the
only way out of this hole is to keep
digging that's not how holes work title
your sex tape why don't we take this map
and this sextant and chart a course to
the restaurant title of your sex didn't
tape ah did not work at all but I loved
that you attempted it title of your
Sexton tape all right let's go you're
getting married right here right now
what come on
Boyle I don't even have a dress you
could wear Gina's I'm sure it's white
there's no way Gina was gonna wear a
white dress to my wedding no I
definitely was but I thought you'd just
wear a gray pantsuit or something I
would never wear a gray pants suit to
your wedding I promise you that this is
happening Jake and Amy are getting
married tonight thought oh my sex tape
you